hi i'm christopher hine and today we're
going to talk about ushiro waza and what
ushirowaza is so i'm going to go from
really kind of general terms about
ishirawaza and and why it's in aikido
and what it is and
why it's really kind of pivotal to
understanding what the system of aikido
is trying to tell us so i think there's
some really important stuff in
usherawaza that we just kind of look
over um so i'm gonna get josh out here
and we're gonna go to work josh
all right let's talk about ushirowaza
and i think the big hint that ushirawaza
gives us and then i'll talk about some
some stuff that i think is fun to work
with through sure wasa so ushirawaza is
techniques that come behind um the word
in japanese ushero just means behind
right so anything that's behind you
different than coho which means to move
behind or to go behind so usher and it's
anytime josh behind me so this is
usherwaza when we're like this okay now
i think a really important thing that
this points out about the system is the
system is built for multiple attackers
not built for one-on-one engagements
like so that's its purpose is one is
multiple tigers the reason we know that
is because we have to train for someone
being behind me boxing has no ushirawaza
right boxers don't practice anything
like this kickboxers don't practice
things like this wrestlers don't
practice things like this because they
don't need to because in the sport we
line up like this and we're not going to
get behind each other
one person it's really really hard for
them to get behind you now you know it's
true that in wrestling there are
situations where a guy slides behind
once they're in a clinch and there are
clinch positions for it but aikido just
has the whole concept of ushirowaza and
the only reason that really could be is
because there's a second attacker i mean
i guess we could have ninja sneak
attacks or something but it's most
likely because there's a second attacker
all right now how do we start to address
it so i think an important thing to
understand is that aikido's basic answer
for this is generally sotomawari and so
a sotomori from ushiro is simply this
right so that's an
a sotomori an outside turn so if we were
facing each other outside turn looks
like this if i'm this way outside turn
looks like this right but i'm trying to
turn to the outside right so outside of
josh
and then of course we do have 45s and
triangles and other stuff that's in this
but that's our main idea
when we're doing that our we also want
to have the hand up that we're turning
to so if i'm turning to my right i want
to have that hand up and it does a lot
of great things one thing it does is it
gets josh reacting to me so you notice
how josh's hands come up because you
don't want me hit him in the face so his
hands immediately start coming up and
that gives me a position to turn off of
right so i got a position turn off of
and plus i'm already putting up some
kind of defense in the area so even if
we're next to each other when i turn
like this my hand is up so if he rushed
at me i'm already in a basic defended
position right
so whatever side we turn to when we
suspect someone's coming at us we put
the hand up of the side we're turning to
so a good drill to get your students
starting to work with this is just a
really simple shove from behind drill
and come in and push me and when he
comes in and pushes me i want to let him
push me and turn with it okay so real
simple now uh what's going to happen
with your students is it's going to look
like this probably
right so that's one thing that happens
here's another thing that happens
right so that happens a lot okay so
you'll see a lot of that so this is a
good practice for coke you learn to
become relaxed and then when he hits you
try not to be shocked by that just roll
with it turn your hand up and move to
the outside right so that's a good way
to get them starting to work with it's a
really good practice this also gives you
kind of a moment to start kind of
talking about sixth sense kind of stuff
[Music]
and and then there's something else
right some sixth sense that psychics or
few fortune tellers have like some kind
of thing like that right so i believe
when someone comes in to push me right i
can kind of start to get the idea and
right you see there it's real smooth
because i kind of have the idea of when
he's coming now i didn't do that because
i looked at him so i wasn't judging him
by sight it wasn't exactly that i could
hear him although i could kind of hear
him and i could kind of time what he's
doing in my head so i kind of had an
idea of what he was doing and it's not
as
magic power it's just simply i kind of
understand what's going on and so i can
kind of work with that and so then you
can kind of start to work with can you
get them to touch lighter right without
freaking out and spinning around right
so that's a good thing to start to work
with then you can start to work with
suppression from this position so let's
say josh comes in and so as josh comes
in and i turn i kind of find a way how
can i get behind josh right and i can
start to work with my suppression like
that okay so
pre-grab there is a ton of stuff that
you can work in there right and you can
work with them and talk to them about
like how your mind can pay attention to
things how you can see them in your
mind's eye this is really good practice
in geowaza when they're moving around
you can kind of track them in your head
gets them to work on coke you so they
can be relaxed and calm when it happens
and not be shocked and not resist really
hard so it's a really good practice to
start to work with with your students on
that i think it sure was us really
telling about what aikido is about
because there is so much you share a
waza there's a lot of usherawaza and
aikido it's an important piece of the
system so i think that's a good thing to
point out as well
i think i'll give you the basic overview
of that i'm christopher hines joshua
teehee and my solano mcdaniel just snuck
over to that camera right there and then
she's got a like a little jaunty sailor
kind of thing going on um
i wonder if they heard her laugh she
laughed she laughed even we got her got
her all right uh so that's it for this
video and it sure was we'll see in some
future videos
[Music]